what up space fam golsan here from anime
uproar back at it again to discuss the
latest and craziest developments in the
one punch man story we got so much crazy
interesting stuff in this chapter
including one of my favorite story lines
right now so make sure to stay tuned for
this one if you do enjoy seeing these
one punch man reviews and want to keep
them coming channel the k baldy within
and serious punch that like button with
no mercy remember smashing that like
button is one punch man energy and
passing is fear or ugly energy so choose
wisely if you haven't make this the
video you subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications or you will miss
future one punch man updates that's just
the way it works and while you wait for
the next chapter to drop feel free to
check out my growing one punch man
playlist that includes videos on all the
s-class heroes dragon and god level
monsters and much more link to that is
in the description now without further
ado let's jump into its spoilers and all
the cover page is fantastic here showing
king atomic samurai and bang on one side
with golden sphere ugly and homeless
emperor on the other and in the middle
between the humans and monsters we see
garo on the bottom and saitama and
friends on top this to me could very
well be foreshadowing that we'll be
seeing saitama sooner rather than later
as we see saitama staring at king i said
we might see saitama soon last chapter
and many pointed out that it was king at
the end of the chapter who was getting
the attention of the black s's the cool
thing is king often attracts saitama so
it's still a good sign even if we don't
see him quite as soon as i would have
liked to but back to this chapter we see
homeless emperor going crazy with his
energy spheres yain and mustachio are
having trouble as is deflecting all
these attacks and homeless emperor just
looks bored he's not just focusing on
overpowering them here but he's trying
to do all this with a comfortable rhythm
as he says so he's clearly holding back
he's practicing control as they struggle
for their lives and even says he plans
to kill billions after this so he can't
get tired this early on so yeah if
homeless emperor has his way sounds like
he's going after the entire population
of the world so as often is the case
with superhero stories our heroes are
literally once again standing between
the monsters and the end of the world
and if homeless emperor can back up his
claims then he's obviously a threat to
the survival of humanity and thus by
definition a god level threat but
whether anyone here actually is a god
level threat i'll let you guys discuss
that in the comments in the meantime we
catch up with atomic samurai who is
planning on unsheathing the sun's sword
in the flashback it's called a
telepathic sword that judges the wielder
to decide if they are worthy of it
lending its power to them if you aren't
accepted you can't take out the sword
from the sheath absolutely love this
king arthur-esque detail i gotta say
this side story is almost too good for a
side character i usually feel like a
main character should have such hyped up
power-ups but i'm not complaining this
is one of my favorite aspects of the
story right now but if this was demon
slayer this would definitely be a main
character related thing just saying
anyways back to the insanely interesting
sword story atomic samurai laughs in the
flashback saying it sounds like a myth
or even like a fairy tale and if
monsters espers and superheroes weren't
running around i might feel the same way
we jump back to the prez as homeless
emperor goes to drop a giant energy orb
on them as atomic samurai is trying to
communicate with the sword and figure
out what it wants bang crosses his mind
the master that he considers to be his
rival i really love this aspect too and
it's another example of how one punch
man incorporates a long line of martial
arts stories and histories into its own
story atomic samurai pictures what
bang's mentality would be if it was a
stream of water and the state of mind
would be a reflective water surface
which of course suggests calm and
control atomic samurai reaches for that
unparalleled level of concentration and
the sun blade responds like arthur
pulling the sword from the stone except
even more epic it starts to emerge from
the sheath his speed seems to increase
dramatically too to the shock of the
bystanders as he moves quickly to cut up
and destroy homeless emperor's massive
energy sphere which he does very
successfully and very quickly we get an
image of him with the sword of light and
he looks reminiscent of yorichi and
dimitsare and his eyes will definitely
remind you of garo here as well not sure
if this is a straight up demonstrator
reference or if they're just working
with the same japanese myths but
nonetheless i'm loving it atomic
samurai's level of strength here is no
doubt monstrous the sword seems to be
merging with his hand and bringing out
his body's max potential none of
homeless emperor's attacks work against
atomic samurai and homeless emperor is
only saved from being sliced up because
the insanely powerful golden s comes
between them to take the attack now
golden s has been hyped up big time even
if you don't consider him a god level
threat which is one thing he is still
way way stronger than an average dragon
level threat that can't be denied to
golden s atomic samurai looks like he
might have undergone monsterization but
then says no this sword must be the
reason he decides to try to break it and
his arm gets sliced off this an
absolutely insane development he
comments that his right arm of 12
trillion cells has been cut off this is
a big reveal too because there was a
question of whether or not this golden s
had less cells than in the webcomic but
now it's revealed that he clearly has
more in the webcomic there were less
than 11.5 trillion cells but now just
golden s without all the yet to be fused
black s's and there's a lot of them has
more and yet atomic samurai slices him
easily with the sun blade an utterly
shocking development i gotta say i did
not care about atomic samurai that much
in the web comic but his storyline right
now is one of the most interesting ones
in the manga think about what will
happen if he gets the moon blade too and
uses them simultaneously we're talking
way beyond bang and tatsumaki power easy
despite the fact that he's currently
only ranked number four of course such
insane power must come with a catch
especially when it happens so quickly
and there does appear to be a time limit
for now the sword goes back into the
sheath and atomic samurai is brought to
his knees from utter exhaustion he says
he got assimilated with the blade and it
completely took over his spirit so it
sounds like a sort of blade avatar state
which is amazing and the eyes were even
similar too it's like when zenitsu falls
asleep you don't want to mess with
anyone with those eyes again i
definitely didn't see it coming that
atomic samurai would cut up golden s and
that's just with one of the two blades
atomic samurai will definitely be one of
the characters to watch as things move
forward and of course it should always
be kept in mind when a character can't
maintain a special form or state for
long when comparing them to other
characters but at the end of the day an
op form even if it lasts only one minute
is always more hype than if a dude is
just okay strong for an extended period
of time that's just the way it works and
shonen just look at baryon mode however
the limit is coming into play already
here in the story as homeless emperor
and golden s realized that now is the
time to strike him down they can tell
that atomic samurai is completely
depleted and he even says something i
remember straight out of the webcomic
goldeness says that all the heroes who
are still alive should form a line and
wait for their turn to get killed love
this antagonist's arrogance i gotta say
especially after getting his arm cut off
but then the sound is heard and they
witness king looking down on them in
epic fashion it's such a morale boost
like goku himself just made it to the
scene all the heroes including genos
think they are saved the black s's
comment that this is troublesome as they
heard he destroyed elder centipede with
a single attack which was of course
saitama metal bat is here too but since
he sees kang he thinks that everything
will be fine he'll just stay back and
let king do his thing while he takes
care of any black s's that try to get in
the way a black s actually calls him out
saying it's going to be satisfying to
beat up the world's strongest human and
hilariously enough golden s the
strongest one is the one to tell him to
wait a minute they shouldn't be hasty
because the one in front of them is the
hero association's strongest fighter we
see that atomic samurai just took his
arm off and so it makes sense that he'd
be cautious around the guy who's
supposed to be much stronger golden s
goes on to say he is king the greatest
obstacle they should be more cautious
than with tatsumaki at full power golden
s tells them to do it together meaning
he might want all the remaining black
s's to fuse with him making the ultimate
goldeness or even platinum s who knows
in the manga and that should heal his
missing arm too in the meantime king is
hilariously panicking in his head as
usual as the enemies think he's laughing
at them and looking down at them king
thinks if only saitama was here and then
as if an answer to his prayer and as if
pulling our collective chains too king
hears what he thinks is saitama coming
to the rescue and then we're all
disappointed together when we see child
emperor and puripuri prisoner there
instead not gonna lie it's a bit
disappointing but nonetheless hilarious
as they look in relief at him thinking
that with king here they can win this
for sure king is as nervous as ever
thinking give me a break and that is the
end of this chapter the next chapter
will no doubt contain hilarious moments
of golden s and the black ss
overestimating king's power which i
can't wait to see and saitama is no
doubt gonna make an appearance
eventually so we have that to look
forward to as well after all king can
only bluff for so long and it's usually
saitama who shows up to back up his big
talk and all all-around great chapter
humor action and information-wise i'm
absolutely astonished at atomic
samurai's powers and as i keep saying
he's now one of the most interesting
heroes to me his arc is definitely going
to be legendary if it pans out he's
already shown a power way greater than i
expected him to and i guess that's the
great thing about one punch man like in
the justice league there are plenty of
heroes to choose from and you can take
an interest in a lot of them yet another
reason to love the manga and not assume
that it's just a copy of the webcomic if
i remember correctly the sunblade and
moonblade weren't even mentioned and
atomic samurai definitely didn't do
anything this shocking in the webcomic
but that is it for this one as always
let me know your thoughts on this
chapter and what you're most looking
forward to seeing next who was your mvp
this time around i gotta go with atomic
samurai or the sunblade itself which
seems to have a life of its own or i
guess their combined state if you do
enjoy seeing these one punch man reviews
and want to keep them coming channel the
cape baldy within and serious punch that
like button with no mercy remember
smashing that like button is one punch
man energy and passing is fear ugly
energy so the choice is yours if you
haven't make this the video you
subscribe and this is crucial hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one punch ran updates that's just the
way it works and while you wait for the
next chapter to drop feel free to check
out my growing one punch man playlist
that includes videos on all the s-class
heroes dragon and god level monsters and
much more link to that is in the
description and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you